so many of the entrepreneurs we talked
to are making this mistake so I had this
many businesses at the same time I
wasn't making no money do I think that I
could
I'm strong enough to own those
businesses now but then I wasn't I had
to peel weight off the bar until I was
left with one and then I did more reps
with that one and then I was able to
level up my entrepreneurial skill set on
a clear opportunity of all of the
opportunities that I was best at you
have to just say no the opportunities
that you have to say no to increase in
attractiveness as you get better what
happens is you get to 100 then you do
another thing and then your attention
split and then you can't get past you
you have to peel the weight off the bar
then you do more reps and so the only
reason you shouldn't be doing more reps
and adding to the bar adding to the
stuff that you sell is that you
literally have no more people to sell to
and until you have that problem you
should focus on the one thing